im namen deines sohnes jesus christus
zur vergebung der sünden tut dies zu
meinem gebet ist
[Musik]
seine kirche ist das zirkuszelt tellers
gottesdienste sind anders laut
unbekümmert spektakulär
[Musik]
daraus gewinnt sondern herrgott und aus
seinem geschenkten der ablauf weckt alle
säle darin ruft zur freud und sind
exaltierten die elogen skript und dass
sich frohe botschaft erfahrbar zu machen
warum dient diese man dem lieben gott
ausgerechnet in dieser glitzerwelt davon
handelt dieser film
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo hallo familie gut ja das ist ja
ich bin wahrscheinlich einbringen jetzt
kinder du nicht schon ein bisschen hier
familie zu hause
es ist mitte märz nach der langen
winterpause ein erstes wiedersehen
zwischen zirkus fahrer im feld und den
zirkus angestellten und artisten aus
aller herren länder und
religionsgemeinschaften alles gute hey
du hast ein verrückt ja und das ist auch
sehr schön gepflegt wurde franziska
freue mich mit dir auf den weg
der zirkus für heller ein mikrokosmos
religiöser toleranz kondition betrifft
zur der buddha dann nämlich denken und
handeln sparversion glauben denn wir
können vor der religionen ein
model lena gercke 70 wenn wir das auf
der ganzen welt und anderer stelle wird
und ich immer konkurrenzkampf für die
fundamentalistischen strategie die der
ehc verfahren
[Musik]
in zwei tagen ist premiere die artisten
sind eben erst im zirkus nock
eingetroffen
jetzt wird am programm gefeilt viele
artisten sie ziel sorge ehrenteller zum
ersten mal
um die süßen land das ist der förster
kompliment dazu sagen dass sie kompetent
[Musik]
und die freundin hallo wie geht s schon
auf kind liebte ernst heller den duften
sehr genießt 1999 modems teller erster
offizieller fahrer alle zirkusfamilien
und ihre angestellten in der schweiz für
schausteller und markthändler die
mitglieder seiner riesigen fahrenden
gemeinde wechseln ständig und müssen
zudem auf engstem raum zusammenleben
um zwei familien durch würde ich lieber
verlangt
und da kommen natürlich schon august
liegen und wo direkten zu mir wenn ich
wo ich ihnen auch mediation machen mal
strich recht motor co ltd
oder wenn sie wirklich vw händlers in
verbindung mit der heimat bleibt
geschlossen bleiben
in zeiten da ich bin erstaunt ich hatte
ich gern schätze dich oder junge
artisten so unter druck sind dass man
sie vertikal und bestärkt rollstuhl wenn
sie hartz training hat unter trainer mit
dem der krampfhaft um kopien sind und
ein ganz großer druck
[Musik]
wird ausschließlich ehemalige nach texas
in brasilien ist der seite weiß
weißt du ich machen viele leute
zufrieden aber ich selber flagge zeigen
und dass ich fühle mich oft zu erleiden
du ernst war immer toll probiert dann
gebe ich zurück ich denke viel an dich
du bist ein ganz wunderbarer artist der
so viel liebe gibt bleibt tapfer
das werden wir bald teilen von ihrem
leben einfach so tross wieder mut machen
den fans bestätigung und sauber team in
thailand glaube das was du der menschen
und der grundschule menschen
[Musik]
pastorale optimismus professionell und
flächendeckend verbreitet stellas
erklärte lieblinge im zirkus sind die
clowns als jugendlicher wollte er selber
clown werden
ein brotloser beruf konnte sein vater
außer wurde heller zwecks
religionslehrer und katholische priester
maßnahmen das bedeutet energie gespräch
mit dem einsteiger ist das einfach nur
blöd angeschaut da ich für die
dimensionen
also ich wie sage auch in blödeln ihnen
oder gc positiv wollte der im brötchen
auf wahnsinnig viel mannschaft herrscht
ist das was ich weiß sagte ernst kommt
her und genau und wenn ernst kommt dann
wird die clowns und pfarrer heller zwei
berufungen eine schlichte mission freude
verbreiten
das was ja solche öffnen und das was mir
machen
in der comedy in das spiel kann man
vorher bin ich auch öffnet herzen öffnet
und so und das ist tauss muss mit mit
teilnehmen und ich glaube der vergisst
oft street und und stress und
krankheiten und wie auch immer dann
geartet bis mittel das auch wunderbar
erfüllten das ist die motivation ihre
tat
die mission zur verbund seit das im
auftrag der welt
[Musik]
auch schausteller und markthändler
gehören zu ernst helles fahrende
gemeinde ein besucher der opfer seien
zur harley so dass er hart ist dieses
große heide schön stark und teller tauft
die kinder der markt fahren schausteller
vertraut seine schäfchen und trägt sie
am ende zu grabe und er hat ein offenes
gut für ihre anliegen
wenn ich nicht viel mehr höre ich im all
dem trubel nämlich auch geschichten über
streit neid und mobilen in der fahrenden
großfamilie
ernst tanner ist mittendrin oder
dorfpfarrer ebene prächtig dass wir das
vor zwei jahren von heute auch schon mal
braucht hat aktuell aktuelle themen
das erkennt auch sorgen und nöte der
beschäftigten an anderen ständen wenn
die kamera ausgeschaltet ist erhält
mancher ein schausteller auch ein paar
scheinchen zugesteckt ernst helles
stiftung die er im auftrag des bischofs
gegründet hat seit ihn seinen lohn und
leistet den markt fahren aktivsten schau
stellen unterstützung in notsituationen
existenzielle sorgen platzierten kostet
enorm viel wenn zumindest praktisch
darum jemand aber stand und sie
eigentlich eben später und dem us lager
denn der transport kostet beim ziel
dieses thema der elektrizität die sind
die unternehmen existenzkampf forum wo
dafür dass wir mutlos werden oder wenn
es ganz schwer uns wenn wir der
platzkonzert doch nicht mit beschäftigt
oder werden sie wirken sind eine extreme
not sind tatsächlich nämlich einzahler
da muss ich im griff damit sie nicht
können im winter schaffen
kapuzinerkresse der kapuzinerpater eher
irritiert mich diese ernst heller seine
laute art seine sprüche er der sich
selber als clown gottes bezeichnet hätte
sie überhaupt und den herrgott und die
seelsorge oder doch mehr um die
selbstinszenierung
ich bin natürlich unter canaria vokuhila
ich bin ein normaler geistliche wo sind
allen sinnen prediger sind zuerst kanten
und es ist auch keine stimmige den
agilen inne und so das konnte ich gar
nicht das ist mein naturell nicht um
mich nicht verstellen
ich bin ich durch eleganz und exotik und
venue sogar wieder prächtig
in dieser kapelle im luzernischen ruswil
träumte der kleine ernst als ministrant
davon einmal selber als priester am
altar zu stehen
seine spätere entscheidung für das
priesteramt war auch eine entscheidung
gegen die ehe in der zwischenzeit hat
heller über 700 paare getraut und dabei
tiefe einblicke in das tägliche leben
lieben und leiden gewonnen
es ist halt wieder unser schmetterlinge
im bauch
würde das von denen und action aber noch
offen haltet ihr das die elemente die
erste stadt bestreitet und die erste
folge findet so und wenn ich noch zwei
trio riss und köder um himmels willen
sie sind schuldig bescheiden sind die
große krach und der könnte die lotsen
und latika st um den tank herrgott mehr
ist für spar probe und den steller wäre
nicht ernst heller wenn er nicht auch
den unerfüllten wunsch nach eigenen
kindern mit einem lauten lachen
wegwischen würde es komisch aber ich
hatte das immer so schön danke weiß
nicht was der einzelne alles mitbringt
was da vergehen hätten sich und das
dampfen problem kriegen irgendeine
kleine kinder kleine sorgen große kinder
große sorgen trotz zölibat es gibt eine
frau an seiner seite seine
zwillingsschwester marine hat acht
geschwister es ist aber immer sein mag
dem ihr ein sms schickt wenn er auf
reisen sicher angekommen ist
mit marlies und ihrer familie verbringt
seine ferien die äußere ähnlichkeit der
zwillinge ist mit den jahren geschwunden
die innere verbundenheit stärker
geworden das ist schon lang vom gegen
das man so darf auf alte zweiter sind
mehrere männer benannt
so eine einstellung und das prägt einen
slot lang das haben wir im saarland
gottes innenausbau mit mehr sitzen also
was erzählt er im frühjahr einfach dass
mir die hand die klinik will smart mit
sperrigen und und das miteinander das
ist das spezielle von screen wenn es
klappt wird man auf kopf und fuß spüre
ich dass der dank frau mit muss man
alles gute
wirkliches graz in der stimmlage ich bin
natürlich so quasi als blitzableiter so
viel verstauen
gestern an der ausfahrt st gallen
hotelbesuch in basel morgen eine zirkus
premiere im jura 50.000 km macht ernst
heller jährlich mit seinem auto wenn es
einen fahrenden gemeindemitgliedern
nachreist maria mir bei aller ligen und
ernst heller standort vor knapp vier
jahren zur seite als ihr mann an krebs
starb
heute erfährt er dass ihr wohnwagen
zweimal in kurzer zeit vom hagel
zerstört wurde
maria mir ist schaustellerin und
jenische sie lebt seit die hier im
wohnwagen ihre brüder wurden den eltern
im rahmen der aktion kinder der
landstrasse weggenommen finales
misstrauen gegen obrigkeiten auch gegen
kirche ist groß ich will mich macht im
himmel habe und sprach mit den messungen
mal ganz gut
es wird trauer nicht die massen anzieht
spiele währt und erlebt sie nicht
möglich sind sie denn katholik ich bin
katholikin die katholisch ich glaube an
gott aber ich muss nicht unbedingt aktiv
im sommer wird ernst tanner passioniert
finales karten gewähren ihm einen blick
in die zukunft das ist total traf ich
liebe leute durch lee logischer könig
mit dem schwert glücklich dass wir
dominant der mensch könne man sieht dass
werte stieg um ganze schönes zeichen
bedient bevor du gleich
dass du willst ja funktionieren und
rassistisches gesagt da musst wenn du
den beruf fertig du die engagiere ich
wollte ich könnte die studie ist und
dass man das mussten das dann als nicht
ob du musst diese aber gleich irgendwie
möchte runden ehe du wirst verlief nur
zwei trainings zeichnet ihn überholt da
ich am mini wort das ich mir bis auf die
russisch wenn du funktioniert kommen ich
glaube der eigentlich überhaupt mit
unserer arbeit darf glauben dass ich mit
so bildet mit soraya sehen in ihm sehen
und ich glaube wenn man mit der sonate
menschen positives kaffee stärken
wenn du dir ab hab troxler durch cajun
das loch ihnen da stehen ja und das ist
genau die funktion banker sollten die
objektiv zeigt die schützen noch
begleitet und darum des vaters und des
sohnes und des heiligen geistes
seine nachfolge hat empfehle bereits
geregelt
der neue schausteller heißt auf den
punkt aber ist der august war anstelle
der extrem präsenz und das verstehen von
dem marathon oder wie es sehr groß aber
ich glaube dort liegt der morna und da
sind große angst hat dass ich keinen
platz haben anstelle das ist überhaupt
keine möglichkeit eines verbots ruhe ein
video und dennoch nicht ab jetzt
unterwegs wir mit denen der sitzt doch
schon vermeldet habe nicht das gefühl
dass armin die platz wort über das
kapital dass ich meine das ist jetzt die
platz da muss ich jetzt schon eines
steht aber seit der grund schmidt die
küste zu wo seine fußstapfen zu treten
[Gelächter]
am größten schwachpunkte
ich bin ich besonders bibelfest brie
nennt tellers gegenwart blitzt bei mir
immer wieder ein geläufiger bibelspruch
auf ihres motorisch werdet wie die
kinder lichter richtig sie liegt
vollkommen richtig als kind was sie
geht's nicht schön dass das kind lacht
ein offenes herz für trauer glück 15
strahler können stühle können
das ist das motto ohne versuchslabor um
nicht immer mit dem würde ziehen oder
bin froh wenn menschen das wird die
straßen immer wieder zudem zog und das
habe ich immer wieder von den akku so
ist es denn auch folgerichtig dass
dieser film über den zurücktretenden
zirkus pfarrer ernst heller nicht
melancholisch sondern in heller freude
ändert
prinz schon vergessen oder sie richtig
[Musik]